citizens of reject Nation next Saturday
1pm San Diego Comic-Con we got a panel
real rejects panel at San Diego
Comic-Con in the library 1pm be there
don't be square but today at 11 30 a.m
we're gonna be doing a live chat I'm
having John on koi's comic corner for
the very first second time and we're
going to be ranking the DC AMU but as
always answering all your fan questions
it's alive so get in there in that chat
ask us stuff away ranking just the DC
AMU you excited job I am so excited we
got so many films to talk about I don't
know how we're gonna rank them all I'm
concerned in advance so have your input
be heard it can be here at 11 30. and
let us know what's going on and we'll
see you at Comic Con we'll see you at 11
30.
foreign